foreign
tourism is a multi-billion dollar
industry it sells wealthier people
access to impoverished and struggling
communities in exchange for a
life-affirming experience
kids would see Vans of volunteers
pulling towards them and they'd quickly
rub dirt on their faces so that they'd
be more appealing ironically to the
volunteers and look like they needed
more help each of us paid thousands of
dollars to go on this trip of that trip
fee almost none of it went to the
orphanage the primary goal we were told
was to build a library our work was so
bad that the local Builders who were
working alongside us would when they
come by and destroy it so they're
talking about volunteerism oh okay to go
do those like missions the feel good the
feel good because I'm white
I mean it's just like it's just rich
people around the touch honestly like
the shit's evolved so much it used to be
just white folks and now it's folks in
my different communities doing it now
um and it was mostly white women back in
the day
um if you guys aren't aware there's like
these trips that people take either to
parts of Asia or Africa or even
sometimes Latin America where they like
we're going to build school or all those
stuff and you pay thousands of dollars
to go do it and you know it's it's funny
to me because like these are generally
like people between the ages of 18 to 24
and
every time I would see people even folks
I went to school with take these trips
I'd always laugh in my head having lived
in Ethiopia for many years and then
lived in Canada for many years I always
thought it was so funny
like you live in Canada you got so many
standards
um you want to build anything you got to
go through an architect you got to do
all this other stuff you got to go
through contractors everyone has to get
government approval the dimensions and
everything and then they just choose
these random [ __ ] who who work
at Starbucks who can't even spell your
name correctly but all of a sudden
they're going to build you a school
it's like [ __ ] who who trusting Sabrina
to put a roof over your head she can't
even write ABA without putting an extra
B in the [ __ ] I'm not trusting her for
nothing
I'm not trusting enough for nothing
that's most of her friends
[Music]
yeah I'm not trusting these [ __ ]
either no but I'm just being honest like
it is one of those things and I remember
these people would take these pictures
and then sometimes they tag me like oh
what do you think like we were yeah I'm
like first off why are you taking me
when you know like I'm one of the few
African [ __ ] you know one two
um two two is like this [ __ ] is actually
so Insidious and so toxic I'll tell you
why they go to these really poor
impoverished communities okay they look
nothing like the locals they don't speak
the language they have no connection
okay and these are generally a lot of
impoverished kits and orphans all this
stuff
they go there they play with the kids
they get close to them they spend time
taking pictures they document everything
it goes up on social media they build
these bonds with these kids who've
either lost their parents to war famine
all this other stuff okay
and then these [ __ ] just up and
disappear after building these bonds
with these kids
I had one girl talking to me about the
fact that one of the people that she
made a contact with over there still
contacts her to this day and like she
can't handle a relationship it's too
intense and like so she ignores the
messages I'm like you dumb [ __ ]
you're the one who took this child who's
lost most everything got really close to
him feel perfectly fine with keeping
your [ __ ] pictures with the
individual on your social media but you
can't maintain a bond with the
[ __ ] of course of course you
look stupid in this [ __ ] so what
happened she never replied to this
[ __ ] what happened you adopted a
dog and shot him in the back of the head
and when he was too much
listen listen the same ammo listen this
is this is [ __ ] boy Behavior a tourism
Edition okay and
and for me I always never
it is certain Affairs for the places
involved as well because now these kids
their only perception of whiteness in
these rural areas is of those who come
in you know take a bunch of pictures
treat them as tools and then disappear
that's weird ain't it imagine just being
treated like a zoo attraction because
that's what it is let's go check out the
Safari with little poor African [ __ ]
that's what this is no it's with the the
there's a feeling that you're helping
I'm not saying that every tour is like
that and every everything that people do
like that is like that but yeah it does
raise a question like what are you doing
it's more than just a tour when you go
to the zoo it's more than that because
when I go to the zoo yes I do it for me
but I just want to see nice things when
they do these kinds of things is I
actually want to feel like I'm helping
like I'm doing something you know what I
mean I and and I always look at that
[ __ ] weird like I understand some of
people I know
um
go in these tours and stuff like that
right
but I always that that question is
always in the back of my head like okay
but what's underlying
what
what's under there let me mean there's a
lot of people that need help here
you know what I mean you got your own
people suffering here
you actually like what is the thought
process like there's something I cannot
help but be like hmm I don't know
listen it's ego-inducing imagine
spending five grand to go lay down
bricks there and get torn down right
after you [ __ ] leave if you really
cared you could have donated to an
organization that actually does a lot of
the labor and would do it properly and
do it far more effectively but you do
this for your own ego that's what this
is for well the reasons for well the
reason why they don't donate to those
Industries and stuff like that which I
the reason why I wouldn't donate but I I
don't trust them and there's been some
of these but because there are so many
of these organizations that say oh
please pledge money pledge money we're
going to build this we're going to build
that and actually take the money and
never build [ __ ] and big organization
like you know Red Cross and everything
they did some [ __ ] in Haiti that was
foul as [ __ ]
foul where you raised six millions and
then you only Built six houses and when
I'm talking about six thousand I'm
talking about four walls each house is
not house houses you know I mean so at
some point you look at that they're like
you know what let me go over there and
help myself so I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be ready to take it on like One
Direction only and be like oh if it's
that then it's fat I'm not going to say
that now oh if you're going to help it's
actually your ego I'm not gonna say that
but it does raise a question it is your
ego and it's a lot of arrogance because
people who are not from these places
who've never set foot in there want to
walk in and think they can help you
can't help you don't even really
understand the problems you don't have
the skill set you go in there for two
weeks what are you gonna [ __ ] help
you have zero conception of like the
culture from a first person standard you
can't help I understand what you're
saying about ngos there's plenty of
corrupt ones absolutely that's also your
responsibility not just to give money to
people but to do extensive research to
make sure your money is actually going
where you are of course with
organizations as big as the Red Cross
you're going to have certain chapters
that are corrupt you're gonna have
certain people within that we're gonna
steal money but yeah people talk about
oh I want to go down there and help
myself if you're not going there for an
extended period of time you just jerking
yourself off
what is two weeks gonna do
you don't even have time to [ __ ] meet
enough locals to understand anything let
alone have the conversations
how are you going to help
I don't care so much about people
wanting to make themselves feel good you
know you want to jerk yourself off you
want to throw money into some greedy
person's hand who's going to sell you on
the experience like listen some people
go skydiving you want an experience go
get your experience I don't care and my
issue is not even with people wanting to
go back to understand and see for
themselves I think everyone should but I
think the arrogance of thinking you can
help that one is what I'm I'm against
just go to learn and understand start
there you can't fix a problem unless you
really understand what it is and you
won't learn about it on Facebook posts
so you gotta actually sit there and
spend time you got to see the
intricacies of the system because guess
what corruption ain't simple poverty is
not simple it's not you throw it you
gotta really understand it and so you
want to go back and understand and see
for yourself go for it but don't feed me
this [ __ ] about you helping you're
not helping you're feeding your own ego
which is
Everyone's entitled to that but when it
comes at the expense of these
communities it comes at the expense of
these places
and who are these people you're putting
money
because they're using these people too
don't exactly sound like the most
stand-up people
I could be wrong but you want to talk
about giving money to the wrong ngos hey
these tourism people probably not the
best people either
right so because there have a vested
interest in keeping the community as
poor as possible to continuously
generate income so go ahead how do they
call it volunteer tourism
the minute you put tourism
is weird yep because then then it's
linked to profit tourism is gonna let me
see the world what are your Latin I can
show you the world no it's weird
so you make a whole business out of it
in an ecosystem ecosystem however the
[ __ ] you say that word
of businesses linked together in order
for you to see the world and feel that
you're helping sexual tourism
benefits tourism there's always a
benefit someone that benefits it's weird
the local Builders who are working
alongside us would come back while we
were sleeping and undo our work and redo
it
I told one of the chaperones from my
school on the trip about what I'd seen
and was advised to keep it to myself you
have stories of people donating bags
full of toys that the orphanage director
then goes and and gives to his own kids
or sells or locks in a closet so the
next group of volunteers will donate
bags of toys because if they see kids
playing with tons of toys they won't
bring toys if they see kids sleeping on
a good bed with a good mattress they
won't donate money for better beds and
better mattresses I've been involved in
voluntourism for over a decade the
language used by voluntourism tends to
be along the lines of you can change the
world and find yourself all at the same
time I wanted to physically go out to be
that change make a difference be a
global citizen I definitely was thinking
about how it would look when I applied
to college and how I would look on my
resume I convinced my parents to pay a
couple thousand dollars for me to be
able to go on this trip to Tanzania it
was about three weeks long we were a
predominantly white group when I was in
Tanzania a young woman was questioning
her sexuality and was being encouraged
by this volunteer to live openly the
reality of this young woman's life was
that she lived in a community where
doing so would put her very great
physical danger and so this volunteer
was so focused on her own moral compass
and moral values that she
that that's that's going into another
country not knowing what's going on and
how people interact and what's the and
just being like no what you should do is
throw a little this and that that's
wrong that's just you judge how'd you
call that ethnocentrism you judge other
people according to your own values and
you're like yeah no that's how it oh my
God and then you put [ __ ] in
danger so it's like it's like it's like
whenever you know you had white friends
whenever you had white friends and your
wife friend would say uh if your mama
hits you just call the police no no I
will die before the police gets here and
that's what happened in your house
wow so earlier I said
you can't help by going somewhere for
two three weeks you don't even
understand the problem you don't
understand the culture how could you
ever
you have these people go in here imagine
going to [ __ ] Uganda
why are you gay there
seeing a young child who may be confused
about his young Ugandan child and you
come in here from [ __ ] San Francisco
[ __ ] butt plugs out there whatever
you got going on shout outs to you
rainbows leprechauns what does that have
to do you know I mean listen live
whatever you got you went from butt
plugs to leprechauns right because
rainbows and leprechauns a lot of Golds
okay okay
and you come here and you're starting to
talk to this person without taking the
time to understand you're coming in from
your own cultural experience and theirs
and there's no what do you mean you live
in Jamaica you should totally come out
to your parents what like do you guys
understand why I say the Insidious stuff
isn't necessarily the money and them
virtues I don't care the problem is the
communities that they get involved in
and how bad it is for them this is the
issue you couldn't quite see how the
advice she was giving this young woman
could potentially kill her
the directors of the orphanage did not
see the Children's Health as a priority
we were advised by other long-term
volunteers at the orphanage that when
residents did get malaria despite there
being money to pay for them to get
medical care they were not provided with
Medical Care the leadership of the
orphans were unwilling to spend the
money
eighty percent of children who live at
orphanages
have not lost one or both parents
they are not orphans they don't have
birth certificates they don't have IDs
no one knows who they are or where they
are these children are Anonymous the
thing that really haunts me is the
connection between orphanages and child
trafficking there's a story that broke
out a little while ago about this white
dude from England who went to Thailand
and and it's such like somewhere on the
Deep Web a bunch of images are showing
up of like
anything from Toddlers to young kids
getting diddled okay getting getting ran
through
and it was like such disturbing stuff
but they're showing up at the dark web
and it ended up happening that a sting
in the U.S ended up finding this dude's
name and location and then it came back
and he was a volunteer tourism person
he's someone who's supposed to go to
these orphanages and help young man 25
23 and basically he was using the kids
and like some of the organizers knew
about it they were trying to hide it
because they didn't want the Scandal
back on them or they were getting money
under the table but yes
especially in these places where there's
no laws where poverty is abundant and
anyone can be bought
rich people are people of meeting means
go there and that's where they do their
stuff
you know this is not like something that
brings me pleasure to break the news to
anybody or tell folks about it's just
it's a lot of Darkness once you leave
this kind of Western bubble
in fact people leave this Western bubble
to engage in most of their Darkness
so
when she says there's a connection it's
like
that's putting in lightly their brother
and sister you know what I'm trying to
say anytime you see volunteer tourism
anytime you see ngos guess what they're
probably got a bunch of scandals
involving their Lincolns your favorite
ngos favorite organizations name them
put in the words child diddling right
beside it and there's going to be a
bunch of Articles popping up and that's
just the stuff that you hear about even
the U.N
even the NATO oh yeah the peacekeepers
peacekeepers peace for who peace really
the only thing about peacekeepers is
because they keep pieces on them and
that's it
there are Brits there are Americans
there are Australians who've been
arrested and that's just the tip of the
iceberg for exploiting children while
making money from people like me who
wanted to do good voluntourism is
continuing to grow as an industry during
the I mean the trip providers who are
the most successful we're actively
marketing trips to Tanzania as an
opportunity to escape kovid and pretend
like it didn't exist you can say that
you are giving 100 of fees back to a
community without doing that you can say
those things because no one's checking
up on you no one's verifying that this
is happening the reason why it continues
to increase is that many of the
experiences that are similar to what I
had as a volunteer of having children
running towards me and wanting to sit on
my lap and wanting me to carry them are
still so emotionally compelling they're
still so alluring it feels so good those
people are not checked because mainly
most of these organizations just like
church and everything do not pay taxes
they don't have to tell nobody where the
money goes they don't have to keep a
book why because they don't have to they
don't pay tax to their own keeper book
money comes in money comes out how much
money comes in man how many much money
comes out and where man they don't have
to do that so
yeah
you know to her I appreciate her coming
out to say this stuff and all this stuff
but same time booboo you were doing it
for 10 years
that's a long [ __ ] time yeah
it was a long time to not see the truth
not trying to condemn you I'm just
saying
10 years that's a long [ __ ] time
I'm not I'm not gonna jump on her
because that's not really the issue here
I had but yeah it's honestly sad and uh
yeah every time I see this on my
timeline every time I see people posting
their little pictures with their little
African Child that they claim to love so
much but I haven't spoken to in 10 years
like you know I roll my eyes
and I move on you know
I roll my eyes
I roll my eyes what is this build a
[ __ ] school Melissa shut up you're
not building nothing okay
you have to imagine like think of the
arrogance of thing you're gonna build a
school this is so crazy because you know
they don't because they know they
wouldn't be allowed to build a home here
so they go to these countries and say
they're going to build a home
understanders they know would never be
acceptable yes so there's a certain
level of arrogance
just that concept is [ __ ] up once you
build a house here no because you know
we have standards oh so they don't so
they get crumbs
okay
and it's not like this is like oh I'm
gonna make her a cake it's a home a
landslide happens everyone dies because
you didn't build it properly
what were you talking about
the reason why we have these regulations
is to avoid casualties but you just
think that with you with zero education
zero knowledge anything you're going to
go out here and you're going to [ __ ]
save lives
from what rain
what happens when everything comes
falling down on them no this is that's
the that's the part that makes me
unsympathetic to these young people who
are doing this it's like you should know
better you just don't care to because
you want to be ignorant to the fact
that's it because it makes you feel good
to think you're helping but you know
what the road to hell is paid with good
intention and this is a hard example of
that that's my thoughts